the astros wrapping up this three-game
series against the texas rangers are
looking for a series win with zach
grenke on the mound
good look at your right-hander he's done
a very good job in that astros uniform
17 regular season starts for the houston
astros seven this season
the era at 2.68 the whip at point nine
four he's done a very good job
now bring up shinsu has had the most
at-bats
of this rangers roster against zach
grenky with 52 of them
catch on the way swing and a miss got
him on a two-seamer running down and
away and the inning is over
one two three first for grinke
punctuates it with his first strikeout
of the game
right-hander lance lynn going for the
texas rangers was not
dealt at the trade deadline and eight
starts this season he has that sub two
era that we showed you
32 straight starts with the 100 plus
pitches and every game he has started
this season he has gone at least seven
innings doing a very good job with that
fastball that he has
here's jose tube he shoots one to right
field the astros are on lin
early george gonna test gallow going
first to third
and george will go in head first with a
slide hanging on with that sore wrist
and the astros in business early so
altuve now with a four game hitting
streak six for 14
and michael brantley who has driven in
the last six runs in this series for the
astros drives in another this ball is
going to fall in front of eli white
and the astros on four pitches have
three consecutive hits
against lance lynn talk about an ambush
one nothing houston
i like it lancelin is a heavy strike
thrower a little bit of a cut piece
getting in on the label of michael
brantley but he does a good job of
fighting it off
to drive in yet another run in this
series see if julie can get into the act
he's had a tough series here
guriel shoots one to right gallo going
back and he will make the catch altuve
tags he'll head to third
jose altuve staying down after sliding
into third base
oledmi is moving from third base to
second base for altuve so altuve out
so still runners at the corners but now
two outs for lettings diaz
he's won for eight on the season playing
in just his
fourth game of the year diaz high
deep left field this ball is gone
three run home run oled miss diaz
and the astros lead four nothing in his
first inning
big swing from oled miss that has got to
feel
good first home run of the season for
led miss diaz led miss diaz showing the
quick bat
as he gets to it knows it's gone 379
feet later
zolac still at second for jose trevino
2-1
this one high in the air deep out to
left field that ball carrying pretty
well it
is off that fencing in front of the
bullpen
solak scores trevino with the rbi double
and it's a four to one ball game trying
to go away that one stayed middle in and
saw him take a peek at it i'm sure he
was hoping that this would get a little
bit more carry
another three two curve ball swing and a
miss struck him out
got andrews on a 70 mile an hour hook
here's shinsuchu with the runner on
first base two outs
here's the o2 swing and a miss as chu
goes down on strikes and that's it for
the rangers
here in the third inning five strikeouts
now for grinky we go to the bottom of
the third
astros lead it four to one this ball hit
towards the hole
guzman will gobble it up and he'll have
to get to the bag himself and beats toro
lin was not there to cover
there's one away good hustle by guzman
heads up play to employ the collision
also by
sliding into first base you know joey
gallo
i think he struck out gallow his first
time up zach has five strikeouts today
there's strike three called he does get
gallow looking this time
going away a little tapper to third
tough play bare-handed by
toro and a pick by yulia on the other
side nicely done on both ends abraham
toro to yuli
to retire jose trevino that was an
impressive pick by yuli to pick up
abraham toro his first walk puts runners
on first and second potential tying run
is at the plate now andrews
andrews in the air short right field and
that one drops in base hit
here comes solac he'll score the bloop
single by andrews and the rangers cash
in a big two-out run
that's right a little little hand
grenade by elvis
and elvis having some fun with it i
couldn't tell if there was a
communication issue here
or not between okay he called the diaz
called it and then he stopped going for
it
now he will face isaiah connor felefa
who singled his last time up
line drive speared by yuli guriel picked
it in the air
yulie with a great defensive play to rob
isaiah kinder philippa
ends up being down and kind of falafel
with another bid for a base hit but uli
said not today as he lays out and makes
a great play
stabbing that out of the air so now
first and third with one out and here's
kyle tucker
ground ball that's gonna find its way
into the outfield rbi for kyle tucker
number 30 on the season in the rbi
column and the astros lead at 5-2
great placement by kyle tucker jose
trevino the batter
that's solace at third astros leading by
three
two two on the way and that ball hit
sharply to third base they'll concede
the run
toro's throw a good one two away five
three the score though on the rbi ground
out
so two out of nobody on and the batter
is ronald guzman he's walked and popped
out
call third strike outside corner guzman
doesn't like it but zach granky ends
with his ninth strikeout a season high
and he leaves with a 5-3 lead martine
maldonado stands in against lancelin at
95
pitches this one's set to right field
pretty well hit but joey gallo goes back
he'll look up this was gone
martin maldonado opposite field home run
he told dusty baker he doesn't like to
hit the opposite way
but he hit that one into the first row
look forward to this greeting with the
manager
maldonado gives the astros a 6-2 lead
smee still in there to face two
payoff pitch and that ball sitting high
in the air deep out to right field
carrying well and it's gone two homers
for the fourth time this year
and just like that it's a two-run game
and he'll drive in another one down the
left-field line what a series for
michael brandley with george on the move
he will score
easily two rbi double give him two more
rbis in this series and he has
nine against the texas rangers the
astros now lead by
four so the game continues for isaiah
connor falefa who's one for four with a
single
and a ground ball to short jack mayfield
comes in on two hops makes the play and
the astros
win it today by the score of 8-4